[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss the best moments of groot and
baby groot in the mcu if you liked the
video be sure to leave us a like and
subscribe to the channel to not miss out
on any future content regarding your
favorite movies without further ado
let's get started
when the guardians show up on the
distant world called nowhere to
undertake an exchange with tanelir tiven
they encounter a few raised eyebrows
from the local population because
nowhere is also known for being a hotbed
of illegal activity star-lord advises
the gang to be extremely careful when a
group of kids gets closer
misinterpreting them as young robbers
some of these young children are taken
aback by groot's massive stature groot
with a gracious heart crouches down to a
young girl and generates a flower for
her from his living right hand the act
of compassion instantaneously separates
groot from his associates disclosing to
watchers unbridled compassion within him
that the other guardians at least during
this point during the course often seem
to try and contain astonishingly
director james gunn demonstrated on
twitter that the motivation for this
incident was an homage to the 1931 film
frankenstein wherein frankenstein's
beast trades flowers with an adolescent
girl by a lake this distinction between
the two sequences is that the image from
the classic film comes to an end in a
much grislier fashion in which the beast
ends up killing her while this scene is
short and simple and quick to ignore it
encapsulates groot's delicate gallantry
another relatively short but
unforgettable groot portrayal in
guardians of the galaxy takes place
during the final confrontation between
xander assisted by the guardians and
ronin the accuser a cree lunatic pinned
on destroying the xandarian racial group
when the guardians approach the dark
aster they unearth that it lives up to
expectations they can hardly even see
where they're progressing the guardians
can barely manage to see their
environment when they contact ronan's
crews groot rapidly tries to resolve
what might have been a tense situation
for the team he discharges a ripple of
spores an ample supply of luminescent
microbes each glistening with a toasty
soothing yellow brightness by retaining
out his hands while the glistening
fireballs strongly resembled fireflies
they popped up to be more of a portion
of groot's tangible soul it's a tiny
thing but without that illumination the
squad could have perished on deck the
massive cree vessel at the very
slightest it could have contributed to
the deaths of thousands of people on the
globe further below it has little
influence on the content of the movie
like the flower but it's presumably
among the first things anybody recalls
about groot and guardians of the galaxy
a beautiful sequence that tends to leave
the spectator as an amazement of groot's
bizarre alien compassion as the
guardians themselves are
after having survived the guardian's
assassination plot ronin is paused from
trying to kill drax the destroyer by
rocket who travels his ship
straightforwardly into the dark aster
momentarily expelling ronin from the
equation and seriously damaging the dark
aster itself causing it to plunge
forward into xandar's ground with drax
and rocket badly hurt and the guardians
hold up aboard the falling debris groot
makes the choice that identifies him as
a hero groot seeing his friends in
jeopardy of not having survived the
impending effect encircles them in a
puck made of hundreds of branches
prolonging them into a barrier
protection realm about his friends
trying to shield them from the crash's
influence understanding that he will
take the repercussions groot on the
other hand is unlikely to survive when
rocket acknowledges this he breaks down
in tears and pleads with groot not to do
it curious to know why he's willing to
sacrifice himself groot wipes a tear
from rocket's eye and replies
devastatingly modifying its trademark
sentence from i am groot to we are groot
it's the juncture at which the guardians
become a family they may formally join
forces to share the strength of an
infinity stone but groot's compromise
and proclamation of the five of them as
a single entity are the fire up for the
team's establishment
groot generates the world through a
solitary act of generosity and affection
in the face of his execution it's a
lovely scene for the original groot
showcasing the true scope of his
unselfishness the scene directly
following the collision in which the
guardians start to reclaim their parts
while rocket retains a portion of
groot's fragmented remnants is equally
touching intensified in no minor portion
by the five stair steps singing o child
which continues playing on star-lord's
player as a result of the collapse
of course groot isn't dead but he
doesn't stay alive in the guardians of
the galaxy while he withstood the dark
asters collapse it was only since his
life form can regenerate itself from
whatever tree branches are left which
means the group we are seeing in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 is the
adorable baby groot after trying to take
people back to 1980 to demonstrate ego's
association with meredith quill on earth
in the opening chapter of guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 james gunn continues to
treat fans to a pretty standard action
set piece in return for nebula the
guardians are defending some anulax
batteries from an intergalactic
monstrosity a large percentage of the
battle nevertheless takes place entirely
on the fringes with a camera choosing to
focus on baby groot who inserts into
quill's sound system and starts dancing
all across the field of battle to the
melody of mr blue sky by electric light
orchestra and it's warm and invitingly
adorable and extremely funny while it
may have seemed to be just an enjoyable
prank to frame the opening sequence
around this pattern helps set up the
complete movie both sonically as groot's
humorous shenanigans take up the bulk of
the room while the grave events happen
around that and also thematically as
numerous guardians especially gamora
conveys parental sentiments towards
groot raising concerns that he could get
seriously injured during the battle this
not only tends to reflect baby groot's
new relationship with the remainder of
the squad but it also sits in motion the
movie's overarching theme of the
interaction between parents and children
gamora's unbelievable combat abilities
are witnessed by the guardians in their
first gathering on zandar while rocket
and groot try and capture peter gamora
manages to stand in their way and they
fight her as well while groot was
holding her she rapidly amputated both
of his arms groot's compassion intended
that even when she badly wounded him he
seldom laid a twig on her it's almost as
though he refuses to abuse her even
though he could eventually stop her if
he wished to
this is another illustration of groot's
readiness to compromise himself to
benefit the team
being kept locked together in the kiln
is what originally draws the guardians
together they concoct a flea approach
but it will necessarily involve some
team cohesion which they are just not
used to groot strolls mutely toward the
guard building in the background while
rocket is seated at the lunch table with
peter and gamora rocket tries to explain
the comprehensive plan and their duties
telling groot that he requires him to
get a cornex battery but it should be
the very last component of the strategy
to be conducted rather than picking up
the battery last groot tries to pull it
out first potentially triggering an
immediate and urgent shutdown and
pressuring them all to act rapidly as
chaos starts to break out in the
captivity it was almost a screw-up but
it tried to force the guardians to
collaborate preparing the ground for
their greater cooperation
the countless mid-credits scenes in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 helms
demonstrate the progression of several
years between that movie and avengers
infinity war which was a year away at
the moment groot here shows up as a
teenager in one of them his room is a
terrible mess and he's transformed into
a grumpy twerp he spends most of his
time playing computer games and rotating
his eyes whenever quill comes in and
acts like an authority to figure groot
would demonstrate an infinity war that
notwithstanding his attitude he may
still be courageous but that was still a
huge way off when quill makes a
complaint about groot space team groot
calls him boring and quill admonishes
him for wanting to play that
mind-numbing game a portable video game
at the very slightest the scene is
unforgettable for taking groot's
restarted lifespan to its natural next
step and the joke keeps going in
avengers infinity war where groot can
still be seen playing these games and
spouting off to the other guardians it's
impossible to know for sure what groot
says in the infinity war incident but it
engenders an emotional reaction from
everybody engaged any parent who has
ever stated anything along the
boundaries of put that aside now i don't
want to inform you once more we'll
probably appreciate this edition of
groot who's not in the film much and
just hardly seems to respect but plays
an important role
groot's first presence in guardians of
the galaxy is a parody set up by his
closest buddy and rokish companion
rocket raccoon the viewing public cannot
see the pair when they first show up the
initial point of view is through
rocket's eyes as he analyzes and insults
people walking around a public sphere on
the planet of zandar the revelation that
the person speaking as a humanoid
raccoon is entertaining enough but it's
followed immediately by the discovery
that groot the individual rocket has
been attempting to speak with is a huge
human-looking tree bowing over to drink
water from the fountain in the center of
the square it's a wonderful way of
introducing these characters and the
resulting action scene only adds to it
as groot illustrates his inability to
comprehend genders encapsulates his
soon-to-be commander peter quill in a
gigantic sack and bemoans the slight
reduction of his hands at the hands of
the warrior assassin gamora if first
perceptions are something groot makes
his milestone with the viewing public
keen to discover more about this
powerful yet oddly angelic tree
that's it for today what is your
favorite groot moment did we leave out
another funny or heartwarming scene let
us know in the comments down below be
sure to leave us a like if you enjoyed
the video and subscribe for more content
on the biggest upcoming blockbusters
until next time
[Music]